you know when you go to Russia you take
that attitude like let's just see what
the experience are you have your own
experience of what Russia's yeah I'm
gonna have my own experience to not let
it be what anyone else's and also I've
been to Russia before I went in 95 I
used to work for a company that made
documentaries these guys and I ended up
going along the help I'm outlets it was
the first time I'd ever left the u.s. is
a big had a big effect on me so um do
you know how to speak it
no no I can do my I can do my
instructions and I know some words
I mean I've some time to learn how to
use the alphabet so I can get around you
know me it's crazy yeah and so yeah like
Celtic ancient so really is that what it
is it's a guy named surreal so it's that
I thought what house it's a really care
but it's actually named after a guy who
made it
that's the Russian stuff what is that
Celtic stuff that you know that you know
oh yeah those those rooms the rooms yeah
it's like yeah yeah the letters in
Russia like why is it that why would
they do it backwards like it's the same
letter that we have but it's backwards
right right yeah yeah that's a yah
you're talking about is that what it is
he has the one that looks like a
backwards are yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's what they that's it yeah what
does that stand for over there just
means yeah yeah and we use it like I oh
yeah that chaos so that's how you say I
you say yeah what's up with that H
what's up with that upstairs and H is
the end but that's how you use it in oh
my god so like when you so once you get
used to read so you you always see Peck
dopey everywhere you go right
what's that lemon restaurant what's that
upside down little H so it looks like a
candle holder yeah right there that's
what's that yeah that's the upside down
H uh-huh what happened there looks like
a why so let me take that H and dump it
on its head but but it looks like H
doesn't it yeah they flipped it upside
down it's a week they look at the e
below that like what the fuck is that
thing and so that's a yacht that that
backwards are yeah yeah so you would say
you would use it like yeah and say that
word when you use it like I'm like just
how we use i oh i and we use it like I
and then we might use it in another
reason too yeah Wow yeah
so I mean it is kind of amazing how
different the way we write is
- the way Asian folks do that's right
that's a real freak out that's and I I
think you just have to learn it right
each one of them you have to learn each
and every one of those they're dhimmi it
seemed it looks like it's pretty hard to
learn well it looked especially if it's
not completely ingrained in your memory
as a child yeah because I'd up late in
life I know there's some people who
speak Mandarin but they can't write it
yeah I can't write everything right yeah
fuck it's alien
yeah that's alien mean that the fact
that a whole different side of the world
writes that way in these little
characters so I do have some help when I
go over there I'm gonna tell you
something I got married a few years ago
my wife is Russian ah there you go and
she speaks Chinese so I got a tiny
region right Chinese so when we go these
countries leave and Wow
in English or no yeah so we get along
some people are good with languages man
that's a curette or spanish is better
than mine already just got here to have
russian which has its own using the
alphabet and then chinese uses another
whole deal and english just does she
have room in her head for anything else
I know yeah yeah a hard drive would be
full yeah yeah yeah languages three hard
languages right probably the heart hurt
the rush is hard and English I'm not
gonna say hurt I tried to learn me
trying to learn it it's hard there's so
many ways to say something because they
conjugate a lot I think there's a lot
more than Spanish real and that's what I
have problems would you know
I'll get Spanish words we live in LA but
conjugating birds that you know she can
do it easy because she's like oh because
they conjugate so much more hmm yeah
it's that's this might be the three
hardest language to learn outside of
maybe the other one other Asian
languages like Japanese is probably
pretty difficult
I heard the Vietnamese is tough yeah and
then you know you got those languages
that you look at you know wow that's
great and then you see like ancient
Hebrew yeah you look at Hebrew language
like the way they write like what I
don't know I bet Arabic stuff Arabic
it's gotta be time I mean how many
languages are there if you had a guess
yeah $100,000
and depending on like where you are even
at Mexico there's different right yes
speak the same Spanish down there yeah
in Spanish yeah like you can under it
like because you know I took a couple of
Spanish classes right but I can
understand people from from you know
Spain easier for some reason and I grew
up right here it's hard for me to
understand their the the way they speak
Spanish my friend lives in my friend
Adam green tree he lives in Australia
and he has a lot of experience with like
the indigenous people that live there
because he works in a mining company and
they deal with a lot of the Aborigines
and they have the the groups of people
they call the mobs that's what they call
themselves
okay instead of like a village or clan
or the cause of a mob that's what that's
what Aborigines use and they have
different languages for different moms
so there might be hundreds of mobs in
this area uh-huh and they all have
different languages so you drive I go
how close here's like a few miles I go a
few miles you know he'd say kilometers
mm-hmm it may be 20 100 kilometers like
see go 100 kilometers and you got a
totally different language oh that's all
the different languages that map evolved
to exact maybe they're similar right
areas of mobs
I don't believe so I think they don't
know what the fuck each other is saying
right right yeah that's why we can't
understand Australians right look at
that that's crazy yeah like I don't know
who's documenting all this stuff and
what whether or not they've saved these
languages and they they have it because
it's very likely that like little ones
of them will just go you know if it's
people assimilating to other populations
or move out like you might lose these
languages yeah there's some what I like
about going to Russia too cos there's so
many different cultures and so many
people and I like that I like people
like I guess I get the like I get to go
to Grozny
I've been got to arrive in this Dagestan
the Grozny is in Chechnya yeah yeah like
it's really it was a really cool place I
want to show you some pictures went to
uh went and looked around well because
it's for me what's really cool about it
is the energy that people have about
developing over there right now because
the place there was a war there you know
right yeah there was a war and right now
and they're really building up and
they're really excited about it
so I think it's just uh it's cool to go
and see people who are really a see like
kind of a group mentality about moving
forward you know so what where exactly
is this and what was their war you heard
of Chechnya yeah yes oh they had a war
with Russia right a civil war that's
what it used to look like yeah now you
got a picture of it now right yeah so
it's the ah there is no rebuilding yeah
and there's that rebuilt there they're
energetic about and there's pride of in
its and it's cool it's a co to be able
to go there and get to see it
that is cool to see something in the
middle of a rebirth like that right yeah
that's beautiful
and in that area a lot of places yeah
there's a lot of rebirth energy going on
oh wow so that's what it looked like
right after the war god damn Wow that's
a crazy image